you have another saying that is a
scripts offer cowards either you know
when we came I had a really bad
experience with my thesis with the
writer who was a really great writer and
me but we had a personality flesh and
that he wrote these amazing characters
were beautiful like I've never seen
again but he fell in love with him so
much and that's why he was so capable of
lighting these great characters that he
couldn't hurt them yeah and to me drama
is that you create characters and I'm
your problem you have to get them to the
breaking point you see what they're
really made up you know but he really
wasn't on board with it he always said
you're raping my characters and I said
that's the greatest compliment you could
ever give me let's wait those characters
here and he just wouldn't have it
another catastrophe impaired so much so
much of the creative energy went into
politics you know that that it was just
so exhausting so when we when the thesis
film was done and film school was over
we just said why don't we just shoot
something without script let's not lose
energy in the development stages and it
sounds like a really good idea at the
time because we were just skipping that
stage but of course if we had had a
script we would have shot this movie for
three years then because we were
basically riding in on set and then in
editing so we explored every single sup
lot you know if someone said I remember
when mom told me that is up then we
would go in the next on the next day
we'd go cast an actress as the mom and
interview her and yeah there was that
aspire web that he could explore and
there was no end point insight which is
exactly what the script would have given
me so I think I've learned that letter
script is a really really good idea
because if you tell you where to go it's
like this roadmap before you actually go
on that journey I think in our case
where was the documentary style it kind
of helped us to create this feeling that
what you're seeing are just snippets out
of much bigger scenes you know that
there's this endless
see of material we're just picking our
moments I think that really works for
the documentary style but it also
becomes a really endless process so I
would take that back but scripts are for
cowards and say scripts are for wise
people that have the patience and the
nerves that you go through development
him which at that point I didn't have
but with projects now I am insisting on
having scripts written out even if we
then shoot in the Indian pro-style
because I just want to know the Ark of
the scene i want to know we're starting
emotionally there and that character is
coming from there and there and then
we're ending the scene there so it's not
quite as open anymore but that doesn't
mean that i'm showing the scripts to the
actors necessarily it's almost like a
secret document
better know the structure of them
you